les beaudottes débarque au cinéma
c'est magnifique direction la thaïlande
et
les denrées alimentaires sont interdites
à bourg madame et om pape ap ap ap
[Musique]
ali dont la vache
les bottes d'un os thaïlande sa
braguette
ferme les portes de la cave les patates
ronger pour cinéma le 17 novembre les
dogues débarque en thaïlande
[Musique]
alors je récapitule parce que c'est la
première fois que j'en fais
mais bozzo thaïlande déjà la recette à
trottinette mon petit
cinéma le 17 novembre les pots-de-vin
débarque au cinéma
direction la thaïlande
s'il ya un bouquet elton a forcément
quelqu'un tout coureur c'est la
télécommande cette télécommande c'est la
climatisation il a dit ne surtout pas y
toucher à sa
méthode en thaïlande où cinéma le 17
novembre